so who is this guy Maki exhaled the
menthol brings as he said it throwing a
glance at D before turning back to look
at the floor small pile of ash had begun
to form just in front of his kick
weathered boots calls himself the vulgar
D looked at Maki with a curled mouth
though I never did seem to break the
laws of D physics and crack into a
full-blown smile ever the forged
marquise Pat pushing himself away from
the wall and walking over to the
workbench what exactly is he well by all
accounts he is human d replied taking
another glance at the blurry photograph
of their suspect that was lying in among
the blood on the table or Lisi used to
me hey ma Keeble maybe you'd hear
something coming after all he slapped D
on the back of his scalp shoulder and
smiled the Baron must have sent him d
spat though I'm not really a now Jacob
I am the Marquis shot back if Jacob won
on us that he wouldn't [ __ ] about with
small-timers I guess guy besides he'd do
it himself D nodded his head before
noticing that his friends hand was still
firmly on his shoulder Marquis yeah if
you touch me again without asking me
first
I'm gonna relieve you of the stress of
having to chew your food D threw him a
sideways look as his friend moved his
hand from D skin
sorry mitt the Marquis was still smiling
he dropped what remained of his
cigarette onto the ground before
reaching into his coat pocket
pulling out another and lighting it up
how come he never use a match he asked
he had walked to the other side of the
workshop and was inspecting the edge of
his sword for dents and rust
how come you waste your time checking
that thing for damage Marquis blow out a
smoke ring before plopping himself down
on the hood of the black Trans Am that
they had liberated a few hours back from
the Prophet Gough Depot this fine an
elegant weapon crafted by your people I
remind you saved your life and on more
than nine occasions my friend D ran a
cloth up the length of the blade
removing the drying patches of blood
that had splattered across the store
like raindrops
I would appreciate if you'd pay some
respect it's not the size of the ship or
the cut of the blade the monitors day
his partner replied once again flicking
specks of ash into the air what matters
is the man behind the weapon de stop he
was doing and stood upright to look at
his friend the Marquis wasn't looking at
him he wasn't really looking at anything
as he spoke an arming they shot her into
a hundred pieces but the heart of a
warrior can only be broken by his own
bleed my mentor Angra told me a long
time ago dee the larger of the two took
a moment and took a breath for from
within out of the heart men evil
thoughts proceed the Marquis broke his
trance and snapped his eyes onto those
of his friend mark chapter 7 verse 21 he
whispered for a second the two of them
hung in silence allowing the moment to
wash over them as they contemplated
their next move the Marquis thought back
to the fight that they had barely walked
away from just hours ago the Volgin had
nearly killed them both we are gonna
make it the Marquis said dee did not
answer
he simply sheathed his sword and turned
his back on his friend nobody makes it
na dhih replied solemnly
nobody
you